l'ancien champion de canoë tony
estanguet s'est mis au cyclisme le temps
d'un après midi le président du comité
d'organisation de paris 2024 était ce
mercredi 3 février au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
son objectif promouvoir le site retenu
pour les jo de londres le cadre de la
semaine olympique
on est ravi de pouvoir partager ce
moment avec la génération de 1024 c'est
tellement important au delà des
compétitions d'engager d'entraîner avec
nous cette génération de leur donner
envie de découvrir ces sports de leur
donner envie de découvrir aussi des
athlètes
et voilà donc moi je remercie toutes
celles et ceux qui ont permis cette
opération cette semaine olympique et
paralympique à l'école parce que cette
semaine on va mobiliser 500 mille
enfants qui un peu partout sur le
territoire vont être mieux sensibilisés
à l'importance de la pratique sportive
cette semaine olympique a été lancé à
l'initiative de l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse et des sports
cet après midi une centaine de lycéens
de saint quentin en yvelines a pu tester
le vtt et le bmx avec le triple médaillé
d'or aux jo ça fait plaisir de voir sur
quoi les futurs athlètes ils vont
travailler et c'est franchement ça fait
plaisir de voir un athlète de haut
niveau
ça m'a donné envie de voir les jo et
voir le bmx viau il faut quand même
resituer ça dans un contexte historique
les jeux en france et une fois tous les
100 ans si on regarde derrière nous et
que l'on puisse associer le plus
possible la jeunesse à l'engouement que
cela va provoquer autour du sport
c'est à mon avis ce qu'il faut
absolument pas manquer dans la proche du
de ces jeux olympiques de 2024 la
semaine olympique se terminera ce
vendredi sur le territoire de 50 ans
divine avec la découverte de la colline
d'elancourt le site recevra les épreuves
de vtt en 2024